Windsor has been the place for big
occasions this weekend it's the
christening of the newest member of the
royal family but if you were hoping for
more pictures like this of Archie
mountbatten-windsor he will be
disappointed because the duke and
duchess of sussex want to keep the event
private this is Harry and Megan again
showing how they want to protect the
privacy of their son they have faced
criticism for not allowing any media
coverage on the day of the christening
and for some it has opened up that
debate about what events in Archie's
life they can reasonably expect to keep
private as a member of the royal family
sightseers came earlier to Buckingham
Palace to watch many distinguished
arrivals for the christening of the
infant Prince christenings have
traditionally been a public moment
William and Kate allowed a photographer
and a TV camera to film them arriving at
all their children's celebrations and
told us the names of the godparents
Harry and Megan want to keep that
private - although Megan may have given
the game away after taking two of her
university friends to Wimbledon area
Megan are basically trying to draw a
line in the sand
Duncan Larkin was the royal editor at
the Sun newspaper he believes shutting
out the press just increases the hype
around this small family event it's
disappointing to mix I really like Harry
and I've known him for a long time but
it seems like is a pettiness and a
truculence since he's got married since
perhaps the news of the RIP their
relationship became public and trace it
back to them it's sort of petulance that
over a longer period of time it could do
him a lot of harm the fact it costs 2.4
million pounds of taxpayers money to
refurbish their family home has also led
to criticism of the couple parents in
Windsor were generally more sympathetic
towards the new mum and dad the finance
on the house deserves maybe a little
more scrutiny but in terms of the family
and how they choose to bring up their
kids I think
I think that's that's up to them they
born into a royal family and there is a
point where they will start having their
own duties but when they're young just
let them be kids since he was born
two months ago we've seen two photos of
Archie the couple will hope the latest
official pictures they decide to release
will satisfy the international interest
in their son's big day Rhiannon Mills
sky news in Windsor